is it is it difficult to have 90 million
people waiting for your next word yes
method especially because you know a
certain portion of them are really
impatient and snarky about it it's
really hard to say nobody here tonight
exactly how many of the 90 million are
that way but you know judging by the
responses on Twitter there's a lot of
them but Twitter tends to magnify you
know you can get one person who posts a
hundred and fifty messages in three days
all of which is where is winds of winter
so you know and I'm sure those messages
will be posted when anybody writes about
tonight if any of you go home and post
on your Twitter account yeah it was just
that the Chicago Public Library Sandberg
Award Dinner and george RR martin was
there you know by the third message
someone will say well what the hell is
he doing there
where's winds of winter so you know at
this point that's it is what it is and
you know I should probably leave right
now and go back writing winter winter
well I'd be a button but the fact is I
mean if you never wrote another word
you'd still be one of the most
successful authors in history in certain
by certain parameters yes but it's it's
very important to me to finish a Song of
Ice and Fire
I don't want it to be my Mystery of
Edwin Drood here I I want to I want to
finish it I still have two more books to
do and I want to finish it strong so
people look at it and and say you know
this entire thing is an important work
not a half-finished or broken work I
know it's some of the more cynical
people out there don't believe that but
it is it is true well so yesterday
actually you were interviewed by Scott
Simon from NPR and I thought you were
very game in talking about what it's
like to have so many people waiting for
your books and I have an ongoing
fascination with the rhetoric that
people use because sometimes it seems to
veer out of the realm of fandom and into
the realm of entitlement in a way that
seems to forget that you are a human
person who is trying to make art which
is a very difficult and unpleasant thing
what are your what are your thoughts on
that
you think that people fundamentally
misunderstand something about what
writing is or like what this whole
business is well yes I think that some
of them some of them do
certainly and some of them don't seem to
understand that writers are different
from each other I mean they they will
point out to me some other writer and
you know in the time you've been where
hand winds of winter he's published
seven novels and it's even there are
writers who do that there are writers
who you can practically set your watch
by they publish a novel year boom boom
boom and that's great I wish I could do
that but I can't I never could
a couple novels I wrote around my career
it took me about a year to write but
they were like a fifth the size of the
novels I'm writing now so that's not
gonna happen
yeah I can't help but think I don't want
the all the wonderful young people I see
in the audience to start taking aim at
me and throw things here but we have all
these apples
I do think there's an aspect of a
generational change about this the I
think the older readers baby boomers
like me or maybe even Generation Xers
are used to waiting for things but the
Internet has created a generation that
is used to instant gratification instant
answers they want what they want and
they want it now and the internet kind
of creates that mindset I mean the old
days when I needed to learn something I
would have to like go to the library and
find a book on it and you know find
another book on it just a double check
that it was right and now I want to know
anything I whip up Google and boom
there's the answer in two minutes 120
seconds actually depending on how fast
your internet speed is so it creates a
different set of expectations and but
unfortunately it hasn't been ething the
Internet does but it doesn't help me
write any faster so there it is
and I try to keep it into proportion it
is
sometimes annoying to me that there's
there's so many voices that just want
winds of winter and you know choose to
remind it to be give every opportunity I
know perfectly well that if any of you
go home tonight and bar on Twitter I was
I was just at the Chicago Symphony
listening to Georgia or Martin within
the first three response to your tweet
some of them saying well where's winds
of winter
why isn't he why isn't he writing it I
mean go home try it see if it doesn't
see if it doesn't work that way but on
the other hand I think for the vast
majority of writers including some
really good writers I mean we had like I
said like 80 writers on the stage
yesterday at the Carl Sandburg awards
and many distinguished writers who've
written novels and works of nonfiction
terrific stuff and you probably would
never have heard of many of them
and their books probably sell relatively
few copies for the vast majority of
writers including me for much of my
career the big question is obscurity its
how do you get yourself noticed among
all the books out there and so I try not
to be ungrateful about the fact I have
millions of people eagerly waiting for
my next book because it certainly beats
having no one give a damn about when my
next book is coming out which is the
fate of most writers that they have to
have they struggle with so you have to
keep all of these things into proportion
I do think you know I we came of Thrones
achieving bestseller status the books
actually not Game of Thrones Game of
Thrones was not a bestseller when it
first came out because it song of swords
it was no the second book Clash of Kings
hit the New York's Times list for one
week at number thirteen and then
vanished the third book Storm of Swords
debuted a little higher and lasted a
little longer wasn't was until the
fourth book feast for crows that I hit
number one on the on the Times list and
then then the show hit and you know the
books were already number one New York
Times bestsellers but the show made
everyone crazy about them and it also
made me famous to a degree that I'd
never anticipated in my life being
famous but this happened to me when I
was in my 60s so it's changed my life in
ways that I don't air necessarily love
oh there there are things about it that
are great probably more good things than
bad things but it certainly was a change
but I'm glad it happened to me strangers
it seems when I was in my 60s because
it's given me an understanding of why
people like Lindsey Lohan and Justin
Bieber go crazy I mean
to be a to be a 16 year old kid and and
suddenly have that level of Fame and and
attention and loss of privacy and
thousands of people commenting on every
shirt that you wear or every word that
you say I don't know how any 16 year old
could possibly handle that so I at least
had had a many long years of life on
earth before I descended into the
strange world of celebrity mm-hmm and a
lot of opportunity to make your work on
your own terms and not kind of assessing
your success in that way